[Musique]
madame monsieurs bonsoir l'ouverture des
archives annoncé hier par Catherine
trotman ministre de la Culture devrait
permettre de faire la vérité sur cette
nuit du 17 octobre 61 où une
manifestation d'Algériens durement
réprimé a fait de nombreuses victimes
jamais comptabilisées dans les bilan
officiels cette décision de lever le
secret sur des documents qui dorment
depuis 36 ans suscite des réactions
mitigées des syndicats de police reste
que cette décision donnera en même temps
un nouvel éclairage sur la
responsabilité de Maurice Papon à leur
préfet de police Philippe Boisserie
Valérie fourgniot
ouvrir les archives il est aussi facile
de le dire que malaisé de le faire les
portes de notre mémoire ont la
réputation d'être lourde surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une page sombre de
notre histoire les questions sur ce 17
octobre 1961 sont dures y a-t-il eu lors
de cette manifestation du FLN contre le
couvre-feu imposé aux Algériens et pour
pour l'Algérie indépendante trois morts
selon le bilan officiel ou 200 et plus
selon les travaux récents d'historiens y
a-t-il eu volonté politique ou non de
réprimer qui est responsable la police
le préfet le gouvernement les premières
réactions sur cette ouverture des
archives celle des syndicats de
policiers sont partagés voire opposé
c'est la police nationale qui est mise
tout au moins c'est ce qu'ils ressentent
qui est mise en cause et je crois pas
qu'aujourd'hui enfin tout au moins ma
connaissance on puisse accuser la police
nationale de quoi que ce soit c'est une
institution qui fonctionne tout à fait
démocratiquement et qui est
véritablement une institution
républicaine et il le viv d'autant mal
d'autant plus mal je crois que quand on
pratique le culte du secret quand on ne
dit pas les choses c'est que ça cache
quelque chose or je pense que nous
n'avons absolument rien à cacher nous
n'avons pas à rougir de la poly
naationale nous n'avons pas à rougir de
notre nation nous n'avons pas à rougir
de la République française un débat
exacerbé par le procès de Maurice Papon
le préfet de police de l'époque hier
pierre Mesmer ministre des armées en
1961 le D douané de toute responsabilité
aujourd'hui celui-ci applaudit à
l'ouverture des archives rappelle le
climat de l'époque celui de la guerre
d'Algérie et apporte un bémol sur les
responsabilités la responsabilité de la
décision de réagir fermement contre la
manifestation c'est la responsabilité du
gouvernement il y a aucun doute alors
s'il y a eu des bavures c'est aussi la
responsabilité du gouvernement s'il y a
eu des crimes au cas où il y aurait eu
des crimes c'est tout autre chose mais
pour savoir il faut trouver les archives
notamment cell de la préfecture de
police or celles-ci sont légalement
protégé jusqu'en 2021 il faudra donc des
circulaires peut-être des lois et puis
il faudra regrouper les documents
disséminés dans les différents services
de police que donneront ces services aux
archives la vérité et sans doute au bout
d'un chemin encore très
tortueux